Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
It is remarkable to look at how much of an influence the Roman Empire had in
shaping European society and beyond.
One of Rome's greatest legacies is it's language Latin.
Even after the western Latin speaking,
half of the Roman Empire fell and forest 76 a d Latin continued on for over a
millennium as the language of the Roman Catholic Church Science,
philosophy and medicine and related fields,
the language of law and more apart from its own a direct use.
It is also importantly the parent language of a number of European languages
spoken.
Today,
the most prominent of these are Italian,
Spanish,
Portuguese,
French and Romanian with no small influence in our own English language as well.
In this video,
we are going to take a look into the history,
structure and condition of the Latin language.
Why is it a dead language?
How did it influence all these other languages?
How do you actually pronounce the words?
Well,
let's get to it.
Before we begin,
I would like to thank Stephen Langton,
Max Youngson or Jansen and Jacob wants her being our most recent patrion
supporters.
They join the supporters listed here that help make these videos possible.
The origins of the Latin language are rather mysterious.
It no doubt predates the founding of the city of Rome itself,
which according to legend occurred in April of seven 53 BC Latin came to Italy
with an Indo European people call the Latins who settled in Italy around the
year 1000 to BC.
However,
this Latin is separated from the Latin of Julius Caesar's Day by around a
thousand years and was no doubt quite different.
We can get a glimpse of that by the first Latin writing.
Scholars have found data to the seventh century BC shown here.
It looks like Greek and it kind of is literally the alphabet we use in English
and most European languages is for very good reason called the Roman or Latin
alphabet because it came to us through Rome.
However,
that alphabet came from an ancient Greek alphabet,
which was lit or mimicked by the peoples of Italy's,
such as the,
uh,
trust skins,
the long forgotten middleman between Greece and Rome from the Etruscans.
The Romans learned how to write their Latin down in a way that looked like this
and that alphabet over time morphed into our own one because of Rome.
So if the Roman alphabet is the alphabet of your native language,
you can thank them.
Believe it or not,
these alien markings are the direct ancestors of that alphabet with words we use
everyday carved within.
Look at this here from the Blackstone dating to around 600 BC for example.
It's written right to left like ancient.
The trust in was,
it hadn't changed to left to right yet,
but upon examination we can see that this word is reiki related to the rex,
which meant a king in Latin,
which gives us words like Regal and regulate and related words in other related
languages.
Fascinating.
However,
we unfortunately have limited information on this ancient writing.
Most Roman writing still in existence comes from classical Latin,
what we call classical.
Latin,
slowly evolved from ancient Latin over centuries in the natural evolution that
language has tended to follow and seems to have been standardized around the
year 100 BC.
The first century BC was the age of Morrie's Cicero,
Virgil,
Julius and Augustus Caesar and many other Roman figures who wielded the Latin
language like a weapon and who's quotes you may be familiar with.
Here's a quote you've probably heard.
It's Julius Caesar.
Of course it means I came,
I saw,
I conquered.
Here's an important question though.
How do you pronounce that phrase?
We are tempted to say venae [inaudible].
That's usually how we hear it anyway,
but in fact,
Julius Caesar said,
Wei nee,
we be Wiki.
This brings us to some confusion.
That is pretty common when talking about Latin that we should probably address
before we go deeper.
As many of you know,
the last video I made was a history of the Roman empire.
Now,
if you haven't seen that,
don't worry.
You don't have to watch that video to understand this one.
However,
the way I pronounced the number of words in that video will lead to some
confusion in the comments section.
Some people were actually fairly unhappy about the way I pronounce things.
My pronunciations though I admit we're probably tainted by my English speaking
American accent or pretty much correct.
Although I also admit that I was lazy with the short and long vowels.
It really just boils down to a misunderstanding.
There is a notable difference between classical Latin but the Romans spoke and
ecclesiastical Latin,
a dialect of Latin and I suppose you could say a subgroup of what we call folder
Latin that developed in medieval Europe and was heavily influenced by Italian.
When we hear spoken Latin,
the majority of the time we hear ecclesiastical Latin or some form of a more
modern full girl Latin,
not just with things related to Catholicism but even with as you can see Roman
phrases.
Part of the reason for that is that ecclesiastical Latin is perhaps and was
definitely more common in recent centuries and makes more sense pronunciation
wise to us.
English speakers will talk about ecclesiastical Latin and vulgar Latin and
general in a moment for now.
How did the Romans pronounce things?
I don't know how many of you are going to learn the whole language so I won't
bore you with the minute details,
but here are the main points to pronouncing Latin like the Romans did.
See is always hard like a k sound,
never an s or chip sound.
Caesar is actually Kaiser.
Again,
an ecclesiastical Latin.
This is different.
If you've heard the Lord's prayer in Latin,
they'll typically say paternoster queerness in Charlie's.
The Romans would have pronounced Chili's as Kylie's.
The word column is the word for Sky or heaven.
We'll get to why the word changes in a second.
G is always hard as well,
like a good sound.
Never like a Joe h was pronounced it softly like [inaudible] article.
Though it is suggested that the elite paid more attention to this while the
lower classes tended to ignore the age Maday odd periodical.
The Adriatic Sea.
Jay is always like a why sound the Romans didn't have Jay though.
They generally had an eye and a vowel in place of it.
Take for example,
UDS,
UDS Kaiser to the Caesar.
He octa,
Aliyah Yuck test.
The die is cast.
Are is trilled.
The Romans called this steely Tara [inaudible] pet dog letter because it sounds
like a snarling dog.
Roma Rome,
Rome willows,
Ramidus v before val like you probably noticed is pronounced like a w.
However,
v also served the purpose of a,
you sound around consonants.
The Romans didn't differentiate between the two.
That's why there were these in place of views on some monuments and things
written in Latin where he toss the word for truth was you plural.
The letters Y in z were incorporated into Latin to use for Greek words,
which the Romans picked up.
Perhaps the only civilization that the Romans respected as much as themselves
was the ancient Greeks and over time,
many Greek words made their way into Latin.
To this day,
actually the letter y and French and some other romance languages as I
understand it is called Eclac degree Chi.
Regarding vowels there are short and long ones.
Sometimes the long ones are marked with a kind of accent,
a Macron or sometimes the val has doubled or sometimes marked with a capital
letter and sometimes often not marked at all as the macrons weren't used until
after rounds fall.
This can be important in some circumstances though,
like in the word lead better,
which means book and leave better,
which means free.
Diphthongs ay,
he is pronounced eye like eyeball,
the battle of Kanye,
Kaiser.
Keep in mind Kaiser in Latin and Kaiser and German sound very similar,
not by coincidence.
Aau is pronounced out like house.
I'll boosters Augustus,
our room cold because of these rules and these differences.
You can hear the name Cujo and Ecclesiastical Latin.
Get Goodall and classical Latin and Cicero and our own English pronunciation.
None of these pronunciations are necessarily incorrect,
but I do believe it's important to be aware of the differences and the fact that
this guy's name in his time was kicked ghetto.
We'll come back to kick it all in a moment.
Let's get back to the history of Latin lads and continued its long reign over
much of the western known world as the dominant language of the Roman Empire.
Though keep in mind,
in the eastern half,
Greek was very commonly spoken.
Dan was in effect a second language of the Roman Empire.
As the Roman empire expanded,
many different dialects emerged.
These forms which differed from the educated aristocratic classical Latin spoken
in Rome are called vulgar.
Latin meaning common or vernacular Latin,
not ugly Latin,
although the aristocracy may have considered it as such in foreign parts of the
empire like Gall Hispana in Britain,
this vulgar Ludden often contained elements from the local native languages like
Golish in Gaul,
modern France,
and the centuries following the collapse of the western Roman Empire enforced 76
[inaudible].
When European societies became more insular and detached,
these dialects were essentially left on their own to develop further and in
these more insular and detaches societies through centuries of mistakes,
slangs interactions with other languages and intentional changes in the early
Middle Ages around the eighth century.
We see of course the beginning of,
as I said,
not only French,
Italian,
Spanish,
et Cetera,
develop from Latin,
but also a lot of other languages,
regional languages in Spain,
France,
Italy,
et cetera.
Maybe I should say Attica,
Teta,
some of which still exist today.
Cattlemen and Catalonia,
Spain,
Sardinian and Sardinia,
Italy,
so Denny and by the way,
is actually the closest to Latin of these languages and the Walloon language in
France and Belgium in case we were wondering,
there were also some Latin based languages that developed in North Africa,
but they were wiped out by a future conquerors and we don't know much about
them.
The imprint of Latin is all over the AFA mentioned languages.
They share quite a bit of grammar,
structure,
lists of vocabulary words with not only Latin but also with each other.
True Story.
A couple of years back when I was getting deeper into studying French,
I was playing a video game,
heard a sentence in Italian and understood it perfectly.
It was a more complex sentence too.
I think it used the subjunctive mood.
I didn't know any Italian.
I still don't,
but that is actually common among speakers of romance languages and the deed
learning one romance language would make learning another much easier because
they're so related.
By the way,
let me know in the comments if any of you native speakers have had those
experiences as well,
but for now let's look at some examples to highlight this point.
Firstly,
the numbers in Latin Unos duo,
today's quatre queen,
quick six Septum or Octo,
no m Dec.
Compare those to the equivalents of these romance languages listed here and
again,
French is the only language I can confidently compare to a lot in myself.
Everything else I googled body parts,
brain got to have heart core,
hand,
Montas foot pace I oculus,
weather,
rain,
fluid cloud,
some solar,
wind went Snell.
Next foods,
water,
aqua milk,
lack bread.
Bond is salt,
salt Lee's wine,
Wean them.
We can really do this all day.
It's because of the similarities that some linguists argue that Latin isn't a
dead language.
Many would say that old English for example,
isn't a dead language.
Exactly.
It's just an outdated form of what evolve to be current English.
Someone said the same thing about Latin,
French,
Spanish,
Portuguese,
all just evolved forms of Latin.
Speaking of speaking old English,
just looking at it here,
you can ask why is it so different from our current English?
Well,
there are a number of reasons why,
but one big one is it's missing a lot of Latin.
I would estimate that about half give or take of our language comes from
directly or indirectly Latin.
Why?
Well,
back to the history throughout the Middle Ages and renaissance Latin remain the
language of the Catholic Church.
It still is a major language of the church,
but being the language of religion in those ages,
it was naturally tied into being the language of the nobility,
the language of science,
language of law,
et Cetera.
People would speak their own languages,
but reading and writing was often done in Latin and Lesser Dante from this high
status and use in such fields,
we have a lot of words which come directly from Latin.
Quite a few other European languages,
less related to Latin were also affected in the sense like German,
Russian,
Finnish,
and Hungarian.
It's because of this,
that Latin words and our language tend to sound very big and professional.
Ursa major,
big bear,
Nebula,
fog,
Corpus Callosum,
tough body,
much of the Latin and English however comes from an indirect source.
Norman French prior to the year 10 66 English was a very dramatic language.
Roman British Latin did not sit well with a later invaders from Germany to Anglo
Saxons and largely disappeared English and the early Middle Ages was more
related to Saks and German and the Norse languages.
Thanks to the Vikings.
There was some Latin because of the AFA mentioned reasons and because he ancient
Germans had picked up some from the Romans,
but the big crossover came with the Normans,
a mixed French and Norse people who invaded England in the year 10 66 they spoke
a dialect of early French and from there we get lists of words and restructuring
of the grammar and such things which come indirectly from Latin is English or
romance language.
Then you can make a case for it I suppose,
but it's really more like a close cousin that hangs out more with German and
Dutch.
There are some parts of Latin,
however,
which are a little more unusual and we're probably forgotten for that.
One of the most striking features for beginner learners is there isn't a word
for the or a and word order isn't really important.
Some languages like Russian,
I believe it can be a little like this,
but Latin is an unusually highly inflected language.
Inflection basically means words are modified to display their meaning in a
sentence.
We have this a little bit in English like in the form of verb conjugation.
I see you see,
he sees adding the s at the end there to show the third person is inflection,
but Latin goes much farther.
Let's take a simple sentence to display this who?
Ella,
we'd debt.
Glad them.
The girl sees the boy who Ella means girl would.
That means cs from the infinitive.
We data and Poo Adam a means.
Boy.
We can flip this around though.
However we want with debt.
Who?
Adam?
For Wella,
we read this as sees the boy,
that girl,
but it's grammatically correct in Latin and still means the girl sees the boy.
Now what we want to change the meaning and say the boy sees the girl,
it would be [inaudible] would that [inaudible].
As you can see,
the endings of changed on the nouns and that is because nouns like this change
depending on their position in the sentence,
that word order isn't very important.
Meaning is derived from the word endings,
not the word order.
Obviously that's kind of a foreign concept to a language like English where word
order is very important.
I suppose I should mention though that in normal circumstances the Romans did
have a preference of subject,
object,
verb,
word order,
but again,
not necessary.
It's fun to learn about,
but when you had to memorize all the endings in high school,
I have to admit it got old sometimes trying to put sentences together.
This is all pretty cool for a dead language.
Is Latin really a dead language?
What is a dead language?
Well,
there's a big difference between a dead language and an extinct language.
An extinct language is a language like a trust skin.
A trust gun was virtually lost for centuries and is only really familiar today.
Two scholars,
no one speaks it or uses it to communicate and it doesn't really have any
linguistic,
could descendants a dead language,
however,
is simply a language which has no native speakers and isn't used in daily life.
A common misconception is that a dead language is one that you can't speak
anymore and therefore Latin is only written.
That's not true.
People could verbally communicate with Latin if they wanted to.
The pope,
for example,
does another misconception is that Latin is frozen in time and not changing and
this is why it's a dead language.
This is also not true.
Latin is and has kept up with the times,
take the words or did they not throw,
which means computer or did a full Niamh Puerto [inaudible] cell phone.
Latin is all over the place,
indirectly and directly.
It is still used by the Catholic church,
still using science,
still used by scholars,
still used in law.
It's a language still in use,
but it's not a language in regular daily use like English or Russian or
Japanese.
It's kept alive because it's Latin and it's important the cultures whose
ancestors once used it.
So yes,
it is a dead language,
but in more ways than one it lives on.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
If you did,
I'd invite you to come check out some other core content we have here on fire
learning like the history of Rome video that this video is tied to coming up in
the future.
We have the history of Rome,
part two.
It will be titled the fall of the Roman empire and then at a future date,
the history of Rome,
part three because for a 76 wasn't the end of the Roman Empire.
I invite you to subscribe to not miss out on future videos like this as well to
help with the costs of production.
Fire of learning does take donations on Patrion,
the link to which you can find in the description.
You can support the channel with as little as a $1 contribution.
Special things once again to our patrion supporters listed here.
We are also on Instagram and Facebook,
so come check us out there to Gorod [inaudible].
Timmy orgo for watching.